what's good for us is two weeks of aaron
rodgers on jeopardy and i i will be
watching it i will be recording it i
will be enjoying it and i think he'll be
great what struck me chris
a little mini media tour from aaron
rodgers late last week aimed at
creating some buzz
and
in so doing he spoke to rob demosky of
espn.com
aaron sounds very confident
that he went in there and he hit a grand
slam home run and aaron rodgers in my
estimation smart enough and sufficiently
self-aware
to know that he did that he wouldn't be
out there creating an unrealistic
expectation
if he wasn't completely confident that
we're going to be blown away by his
ability to come in and run the game the
way that alex trebek ran it for decades
so
i was
surprised but pleasantly surprised to
see the confidence that he exuded the
preparation he put into it and his
estimation that the producers were blown
away by what he did
so
i i think that's great i think that's
awesome and i'm looking forward to
seeing what he can do and i have a
feeling we're all going to like very
much what aaron rodgers is capable of
doing i i don't doubt that one bit i
mean i i'm a fan of jeopardy so like i'm
not a re i've become somewhat of a
regular watcher of the show i'm very
excited for it oddly enough for the
second time the show it's my aunt wendy
who got me into jeopardy you know so
i'm i am pumped and i'm not shocked to
hear
you know
him boast like this a little bit or for
him to think this i mean first off
it sounds like he got some feedback to
go like they were like wow okay you did
a really damn good job he is an nfl
starting quarterback so i'm sure they
were a little bit worried about like
going to commercials and how he would
clean certain things up the you know
just the tv mechanics but he's aaron
rodgers you one know he's got great
self-confidence right you know he's kind
of like a psycho and perfectionist and
gonna study and try to do that type of
stuff and then he's got
an unbelievable cockiness about him come
on is there any other great quarterback
we've ever seen who's smiling more or
getting hit during games and still like
kind of laughing like oh this is fun out
here you guys are working but this is
fun i mean it's just the attitude i
expected so i am kind of excited to
certainly be watching it tonight no
doubt
my only concern when i look at what he
said and what he did i took pages and
pages of notes i wrote down every
affirmative that alex trebek said to any
type of clue i wrote down how he would
respond if they didn't get it right i
wrote down beat points of the show i
wrote down all the different ways he
would take it to break i wrote down the
stuff he said coming out a break
literally i studied for this like no
other i wanted to absolutely crush it
it can't be
aaron rodgers pretending to be alex
trebek yeah right at some point he's got
to make it
about himself him being the host of
jeopardy but maybe the transition and
maybe the wisdom of it is
if you start it off
with that
familiarity and if you get people to say
hey i hey wait a minute there's
something you know they have that
recognition that this feels like it felt
all those years that you do that right
and then you make it your own at some
point during the course of the two-week
run and even though it will play out for
two weeks on our tvs or
whatever device we watch tv on nowadays
it was something that was done in two
days that's the beauty of the game show
host gig you work one day a week you
work one day and you get the whole week
in the can and then you got the rest of
the week to do whatever you want to do
in that regard it's a lot like football
it sounds one day a week although
although you still work in between
there's one day when you really have to
perform and and chris i'm telling you
i i watched a little bit of dr oz as the
guest host and he was the guest host the
last two weeks and of course with rogers
with this media blitz and us talking
about it you're welcome aaron it's going
to get more people to watch it and the
ratings are going to spike and that's
going to that's going to catch the eye
of the producers
if he did as well
as he seems to think
he did
how do they not look at the full range
of guest hosts and say who stands out
who should be the permanent host he's
got to be in consideration for it and
people think that's crazy to suggest
somebody's going to be the next host
yeah and
and a small list of somebodies was
on the roster of guest hosts so the
universe can't be gigantic it's not like
they're they're you know doing a
nationwide sweep of the next jeopardy
host they've got
a list of obvious finalists under the
guise of guest hosts so if he really did
kick ass the way that he thinks he did
what happens if they i bet packers fans
think i'm trolling them or him i i think
it's an obvious conclusion
to the confidence he's exuding about the
performance we haven't seen yet well
yeah but if he really did blow it away
they may want him for the job well they
may want him for the job i mean he is
excited i mean there's no doubt about
that he's certainly showing us that like
that this is something he didn't just
hey i'm gonna go in there and kind of
wing it and see how it goes he obviously
invested some time and studying as he
like laid out there what he did writing
notes and all that type of stuff but
like okay so so if he kills it this week
they offer him the show
i mean first off i want to know how much
does that guy make how much does the
does he make us does he make nfl
quarterback money because that's the
first thing we got to ask to figure this
situation out
well i i did a little research over the
weekend somebody told me that alex
trebek was making 10 million a year i
saw as high as 18 million so i'm at
least willing to stipulate its eight
figures yeah plus plus
once you have that job right
you you can have it for 40 years
i mean that's the thing this isn't i
know an nfl shelf-life type gig this is
the ultimate post-playing job for
someone who has said chris on multiple
occasions he's got no interest climbing
into a broadcast booth where tony romo
is making 18 million a year right so you
go to a different route you stay in tv
you make gigantic money and and you do
it for 30 or 40 years assuming that the
show continues to be viable and in this
age of fracturing of the
audience
jeopardy is as popular as ever people
are still finding ways to watch it
they're just watching it differently
than they used to yeah and the show has
has thrived like no other game show so
he gets that spot he runs with it
into his 40s 50s 60s 70s if he wants to
that that's
so
and that that's why i raised but here's
here's why i raised the question
if the door opens
for him right between now and september
and he says no thank you
it's probably the door may close yeah
forever
the only way that it wouldn't is if
whoever gets it flames out quickly
because that person can't
can't deal with the pressure of
following alex trebek and within two or
three years it's just you know we got to
go to somebody else just like a great
coach it's hard to follow a great coach
it's hard to follow a great quarterback
it's high and what's aaron rodgers
followed a great quarterback in green
bay he knows all about picking up the
baton for a great quarterback and moving
on so i think he'd be fine but others
may may falter that would be his only
hope if he said no that whoever gets the
gig flames out in a few years and they
come back to aaron rodgers but that's
that's a hell of a roll of the dice for
a job that he apparently covets and and
look it's we we have to have that on our
radar screen it's not trolling it's
reality if they would offer him that job
what would he say
and i i think you got to at least
consider
the possibility he'd say yes i mean i i
hear you i i think like i would sit
there and think okay
i would consider the possibility of him
saying yes if this was like maybe two or
three years down the road but like at
this point right now
mvp
season 48 and five you know it's the
second year of going 13-3 they're so
close
he's so good still you can only play
football so many years like you're
talking about i mean i would still
imagine this is
what he is and wants to do and his
passion as cool as like jeopardy is and
i'm sure there is a real passion and and
probably a real wanting to like maybe
dive into that and do that
i just still think this is a guy that
has a burning to be
the greatest quarterback of all time and
i think he still looks at and goes wait
i could still win a few more mvps and i
still got a chance to win a super bowl
or two and climb the line that's not
good is that going to make him the
quarter if he was a super bowl or two
with tom brady at seven is that gonna
make him the greatest quarterback of all
time not in most people's eyes no but
you know he'll have people like me here
tauton is you know and saying it i'll
i'll continue but i i just think you
only have these amount of years to play
there's only so much you can play i
think he loves the game too much i would
just be shocked at this point you know
we were a little closer to 40 and this
was like hanging out there
maybe we would do it but i just think
he's still looking at it like he's got
stuff to prove and things he wants to do
with his career before he's ready to be
you know alex trebek quite yet
well i don't i don't think that it's an
easy answer because he's smart enough
right when that door opens it's a bit
you have to make the decision yeah and
and uh what what are you going to regret
more over the balance of your life not
sticking around for a few more years in
the nfl or passing on something that
could be a multi-decade opportunity to
live out a dream and and have
quarterback money-ish
for
decades to come and also a very high
profile on a big platform without having
to be involved in the sports world which
he said he doesn't want to do that's the
key what else is aaron rodgers going to
do in media that isn't sports media
other than host jeopardy that's the key
now now maybe he could maybe he'll end
up hosting a late night show maybe he'll
end up on the evening news somewhere
maybe the guy can do anything yeah we've
always looked at peyton manning as the
example of someone who can thrive in
whatever he chooses to do
i think that's a mindset that we need to
apply to all the great quarterbacks sure
that they can probably transfer the
skills that made them great even though
it ultimately starts with the arm
there's so much more that goes into it
than that
that there are transferable skills
whether it's drew brees tom brady
patrick holmes russell wilson the list
goes on and on the great quarterbacks
probably are set up to be successful
whatever they want to do yeah but if he
wants to host jeopardy
if he wants to host jeopardy
the the uh the moment to make a decision
if offered it it won't matter if it's
not offered yeah it's offered right
that's what's an issue he was on espn
with kenny mayne
and he was asked about his future with
the packers aaron rodgers said so far
it's definitely been my team i said last
year i didn't know if it was actually
possible to be able to finish there in
green bay
i still feel that's kind of where we're
at i don't know that a lot of that is in
my hands i guess we'll just kind of see
as we go and this guy's coming up on one
year
of feeling like his future is not in his
hands because of the drafting of jordan
love because of the questions that have
continued to linger because of the fact
that the packers didn't come to him this
offseason and say
let's
minimize your cap number for 2021 so we
can go out and get more players and in
turn we're necessarily bound to you for
two more years not a year-to-year type
of a thing he's smart enough to process
all that he's smart enough to see which
way the wind's blowing yeah and
the one way chris
that that he
can give
the folks in green bay who are showing
some degree of ambivalence to him the
people in the organization who aren't
willing to make that multi-year
commitment the up your butt joe boo move
right pardon me on a monday morning
would be to to to go take over jeopardy
yeah that would be the that would be the
best exit for him that no who could
criticize him who from the pa he's not
going to be the brett favre pariah it's
like not like he went to play for the
vikings he exited all together
to an equally significant platform that
he's going to have
for years to come
well
yeah okay i mean maybe he could do that
you're right and not ruffle like as many
feathers with the fan base and things
like that but at the same time if if he
wants to make like the ultimate like up
your butt joe boo type of move right and
really stick it to the packers that
means no he would not go host jeopardy
that means he would go to another team
here when it's all said and done and be
like oh yo okay you guys want jordan
love that's good um yeah i'm still
playing at the mvp level and now i'm
gonna go play at a mvp level somewhere
else and we're gonna win football games
and now you got to deal with that talk
green bay
you know because this will be different
than again like we've talked about
before with brett favre this is
different he's brett favre kept showing
opening the door and going look i can
walk out look i can walk out here's the
door look i can walk out aaron rodgers
on the other hand they're showing him
the door they're like here's the door
it's cracked open it's it here we go
like with you're going right down that
hallway there's a different thing there
to where green bay fans would be crazy
to be critical of rogers of anything
he's done
if he did anything to this you know
after this is what i'm saying makes a
decision to host jeopardy whatever it
may be he's been put in a corner he's in
a tough situation he's the best player
on the team
and it's one of the few things few
situations in the whole league
where the best player on the team
is being made feel like by the team that
we like you just here for a little bit
longer and that's about it and there's
not too many scenarios about that or
scenarios like that around the league
and i think that probably does drive him
crazy and i think it should give him the
benefit of the doubt i guess is what i'm
saying with the packer fan base if this
ever did come to this
i think more importantly than the
packers having the well we just want you
here for a little bit longer mindset i
think there's a manipulation involved
and it emanates from ceo mark murphy who
knows
i've said this before that sweet spot of
pissed offedness that you want to keep
aaron rodgers in where he's agitated by
the situation just enough to be awesome
on the football field
and keeping him stirred up is what gets
him in that zone okay what it did last
year look at what it did and i think
murphy wants to keep him just pissed off
enough to do it again this year and
chris something occurred to me right you
know we assume
that the folks who run jeopardy are
going to make some
hard line
thou shalt give us an answer by july 31
or something like that rogers could
broker a deal with jeopardy where they
just kicked the can through the end of
the year with guest hosts and he says
after the season ends give me one more
season after the season ends then i'll
do it he could do that maybe that's the
compromise one more year of football and
he tells the people of jeopardy secretly
quietly discreetly that once the
season's over that's when he's going to
step aside and become the host of
jeopardy this all flows from the
presumption that they want him but again
if this guy's out there doing the
advanced victory lap think about that
he's doing an advanced victory lap
telling everybody what a kick-ass job he
did posting jeopardy unless he lacks the
self-awareness that i believe he has he
blew it out of the water and they're
probably going to want him that's what
this is all premises well let me ask you
this did they do any of these press
tours with the like the katie curics or
the dr oz's or anything like this like i
don't remember like hearing anything
this aggressive like i knew they were
coming
but
i
do you know seriously did you hear like
press tours like this with those that
group what are you giggling i'm not i'm
not i'm not familiar with katie kurick
i i i don't know who katie curie is
katie i know who katie couric is okay
okay all right close enough all right
they got it um but but uh i i don't look
it's not like
katie couric dr oz whoever else has been
the guest host it's not like it's gonna
land on the sports media radar i know so
i know i just wanna if there wasn't
but i didn't notice anything i don't
know nothing made it on to twitter i
didn't see that that dr oz was hyping
his two weeks i mean this is part of the
this is part of the strategy that
aaron rodgers is smart enough to engage
in well look wait a minute what's going
to help me get the attention of the
producers it's comp and even if he
doesn't want the job he's competitive i
want to have the best ratings of anyone
who was a guest host so i'm going to go
out and goose the ratings well that's
what i would think though that he is
doing this because jeopardy
has also gone weight he did a really
good job we'd like to get his name out
there and get a little like something
behind the show and he hosted we thought
it was really impressive aaron would you
mind talking to these media outlets that
i mean you know that's probably how it
worked i don't think he was calling up
companies going hey guys guess what i
was awesome at jeopardy do you want to
do an interview with me i doubt it i
mean maybe he's that cocky of a person i
know he's got great self-confidence i
don't think he's that cocky i don't
think he is i would think something was
you know this was brought to him by
somebody all right and then here last
thing too with their not the last thing
but like to get back to your point with
the mark murphy thing okay
there might be some logic to that i hear
you
but it's the last year you can do that
crap mark murphy if that is the tr the
truth or if that's what's going on where
you're trying to find this sweet middle
ground this is it i mean this is the
only year because after this it's like
no aaron rodgers is gonna have the power
in his court or have the ball in his
court to do whatever he wants here
because it's gonna be like first off i
don't think we think he's gonna fall off
a cliff he's still going to be one of
the best quarterbacks in football and
they're going to have to make some sort
of commitment or something here or he's
going to have to force his way like it
that honeymoon is over about saying like
oh we're going to motivate you by kind
of like you know keeping you in
uncertainty land here all this time so
that that to me too is very very real
and they better be careful with that
because rogers might at the end of this
year just go screw you guys yeah i'm
still awesome and we're in the super
bowl window but you do nothing to really
support me and free agency once again
and we'll see what they do in the draft
and he might just say the hell with it
i'm out of here
the thing i like about aaron rodgers the
most is there are layers and levels and
there's a mystery there and you never
really know
what it is that he wants to do even
though he'll say the things that he
needs to say
i think deeper down there's a lot going
on there yeah and i'm telling you he
gets that opportunity he gets that
opportunity to host jeopardy and that
changes everything potentially and i can
see it most if he wants that gig him
working it out so he could do one more
year
with green bay and then right off into
the sunset with or without a lombardi
trophy but into
a gig
that
he'll have
for years to come and decades to come
potentially if you really did as well as
he seems to think he did
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports